he appears how's it going guys
it's me quinn from quentin's ideas which
is the youtube channel that you're
watching the stream on
right now how's it going everybody
please let me know how my visuals
and sound are as always
let me mute my phone so it doesn't play
my voice
hi guys how's it going so you can
probably tell by the title
and thumbnail of this stream what the
topic is going to be and actually let me
plug in my headphones if i'm going to
actually have them so i can
hear myself ah that's a lot better now i
can actually hear myself speaking
so thanks everyone for showing up and
joining me
i saw that quite a few of you were
waiting
before the stream even started in the
chat house everyone's
night going or morning or afternoon
i know it's time zones don't mean much
when you're
on the internet at this point in history
how's it going guys you guys ready to
talk some lovecraft
as i was saying everyone's saying the
it looks and sounds good we're finally
getting the hang of this because a lot
of times like i start the strings in the
beginning and like the audio is
wonky uh it's not set to the right mic
or whatever but it looks like everything
is going good right now
so yeah today today is a very very
special
day this is kind of a preemptive stream
in a lot of ways because i'm getting
ready to dive into a lot more
hp lovecraft content on this channel um
i've covered it a little bit before i've
talked about
hp lovecraft in relation to a song of
ice and fire
um i have like a i've i've referenced it
in a bunch of my song of ice and fire
theory videos
um i did a podcast episode a long time
ago with order of the great hand talking
about
just pulling out little bits of
lovecraft that show up in a song of ice
and fire
then also a few months ago i did one of
my most favorite videos ever which was
the at the mountains of madness video
essay which was
me covering one of lovecraft's most
famous and most awesome stories
um but yet today today we're going to be
focusing
on a more specific lovecraft topic
there's a lot of interest in h.p
lovecraft
today these days i noticed it's
interesting uh
just a little bit about lovecraft the
guy was he was a weird dude for sure
um he wrote a lot of he wrote some
terrifying stories though
he was never famous while he was alive
um in fact he kind of like struggled his
entire life he kind of lived a rough
life i mean if you really get into his
history
i mean he definitely had some kind of
definitely had some mental issues
he was a little bit definitely
agoraphobic
uh definitely but xenophobic for sure um
had issues with women he like lived in a
different state from his wife
so the guy had issues um
[Music]
and the guy had certain specific fears
he feared things that weren't familiar
to him
right and that's obvious the more you
learn about his life
and that does come through in his
stories like a lot of people
i feel like i need to say this because a
lot of people say
there's a lot of hubbub from a lot of
different sides about lovecraft so i
just feel like i need to say this
before we get started um
when it comes to the work of lovecraft
right he's
not going on
ra as i said in my last stream he's not
going on racist diatribes
in the stories right you don't read
lovecraft stories and find like long
sections about like
why certain groups of people are
inferior or like horrible read horrible
things it's just not there
right he is however a product of his
time so when you read lovecraft you have
to put it in context to someone that was
writing stories in like the 1920s and
yeah exactly someone just said edgar
allan poe was also very weird yes
edgar allan poe is very weird a lot of
horror writers are
weird in general but yeah he was a
strange dude
we can separate the art from the person
um but also acknowledge
when we are reading his work where
certain
prejudices and ideas might peek in
because they i'm not saying that they
don't
ever it's important to acknowledge them
when they do and
that doesn't mean we have to throw away
the entire canon of lovecraft
um because i feel like if you're going
to criticize lovecraft for certain
things you have to criticize
a lot we will be throwing away a lot
we'll be throwing away a lot i mean i
feel like people
at this point for some reason want to
single out lovecraft for some reason and
as though he is especially bad
right which which i don't agree with at
all there's a lot of way worse stuff
that gets
celebrated and pushed a lot of way worse
people that are like remembered way more
fondly like no one ever talks about
walt disney and all the crazy things
that he thought and believed
no one ever talks about that so it's
like it's like why are we singling out
lovecraft i feel like
when it comes to this kind of outrage
it's very selective
and i really really and when it comes to
selective outrage for me it strikes me
as like kind of disingenuous
you know because it's like if you're not
if you're mad about that why why aren't
you mad about the other great
someone says ultimate guide to chapter
house 2 and win um
that will be my next big video after the
call of cthulhu video
that will be the next one so like i said
this stream is preemptive we're going
we're going to
introduce everybody to the work of
lovecraft get into the nitty-gritty
uh specifically in this stream we're
going to be talking about
the great old ones the great old ones of
lovecraftian
lore all right so just before i get
started completely i just wanted to say
this as well
i have not seen lovecraft country all
right
i do want to get the book i tried to
order it from amazon but like if
you haven't been reading if you haven't
been paying attention to the news then
you know that like the american postal
system
is kind of a mess right now so amazon is
kind of a mess right now so like the
book wouldn't get here until like
next month if i ordered it so i'm going
to have to like at some point
make a trip down to barnes noble and see
if i can hunt down lovecraft country
because i really just don't have
any real interest in watching the show
before i read the book
right so i gotta get the book read it
and then i will watch a show and i hear
it's fantastic
and i have nothing against it but no
spoilers for lovecraft country
um but yeah let's move on
and as always guys if you are enjoying
the stream i know we just started but
hit the like button
it really helps get things circulated
and going um and yeah without further
ado let's talk about
let's talk about the great old ones uh
so where do we start with the great old
ones
um these
are beings a lot of people like to call
them gods but they're not really gods
they are beings that were brought into
existence
eons ago we don't even really know
exactly how
long ago and their essential form is is
is their central mode of communication
is is is stopped they communicate
normally through thought
right so you would assume that there
essential core of being is thought
right so they are beings of
consciousness that sometimes
take form and they existed eons and eons
and eons and eons before
mankind ever existed possibly before
earth was even
fully formed most likely before earth
was even fully formed
um some of them might have even existed
at the dawn of time
in the very beginning possibly even
before the creation of the universe
um because these are love traps like
he it's not necessarily so
straightforward because lovecraft likes
to deal with things that are kind of
outside of time outside of normal space
outside of normal existence
so when i say existed before the
universe take it with a grain of salt
it's not really meant for you to
understand and that's kind of where a
little bit of terror comes from
but anyways at some point the great old
ones
came to earth and the earth was
was theirs and they ruled it and it was
their dominion
there are also other beings that weren't
them
right lesser beings and we we'll talk
about that a little bit later but the
old ones
themselves
did not die at least not any
at least they didn't die in any any real
way that we could that we would call
death
what we do know is that they were
extremely
subject bound to cosmic will
the cosmic alignment was everything uh
and that is the position of the stars
the position of the planets
when the stars were right they could
leap and travel from world to world
with ease and and go wherever they want
do as they pleased
but when the stars were wrong they they
could not live they could
not be at least not
at least not be in the physical way at
least not
be alive to dominate in the same way all
right
so that's just setting up where they
come from and letting you know that they
got to earth
so like i said they got to earth the
great old ones very very very very very
very early
this was long before mankind was ever
even dreamed of it's not specifically
said how long ago of course
um hello gray area how's it going thanks
for joining me
so it's not said exactly how long ago
they got to earth but eons ago and long
before humankind had
and it says in lovecraft's body of work
that they brought their
images with them so if you look at the
uh thumbnail for this live stream um
that is artwork by behringer
who did this book who colored and uh
drew this adaptation of h.p lovecraft's
the call of cthulhu and i'll just show
you one of the images here
so i can explain a little bit better
what i mean
by they brought their images with it so
in the body of lovecraft's work
throughout the world
you find idols
strange idols i hope you guys can see
that pretty clearly
it's a bar leaf it's a it's kind of a
sculpture a statue
of cthulhu throughout the world in h.p
lovecraft's work they find these strange
idols
they're made of no stone that they that
they know of it's not
an earthly stone because the gods
the old ones brought their images to
earth
with them right and at some point
during their dominion of earth long long
long ago
the stars changed the stars
shifted and the gods the old ones
foresaw
their doom they saw that they would soon
not longer be no longer be able to live
so they all went to their city raleigh
and here's where it gets really really
cool this is where cthulhu comes into
play actually let's let's
let's take a pause and let's talk about
the most famous lovecraftian great old
one just for a second because
he is very important when it comes to
what happened to the gods when the stars
changed what happened to the old ones
when the stars changed and they were
still on earth
so cthulhu is actually referred to in
the call of cthulhu
as the great priest right
and it in fact says it is his spells
that preserved
the great old ones in relay um
so we can assume that cthulhu was
a leader of the old ones
and so when the stars changed they went
to relay the corp city as they called it
which was this strange strange city
with weird angles made of strange stone
from beyond the stars if you looked at
it you wouldn't be able to comprehend it
right uh concave becomes convex
angles shift it's not like you're you're
looking into
you're looking past things into other
dimensions it is
spaces don't make sense in this city
they make sense possibly to these beings
well certainly to these beings but
to a human to the human mind they
wouldn't make sense right so they went
to the city
they entombed themselves and they waited
they waited and they waited and they
waited
while the stars changed and they
couldn't live
and in their great city of relay they
spoke to each other
in thought and as thousands and
thousands and thousands of years past
millions of years eons passed at some
point
humans developed consciousness
and the gods the old ones whose
form of communication is a language of
pure thought they spoke to the first men
in their dreams now i actually have
a specific quote which i don't have
pulled up for some reason so i would
just like
grab it from here
we'll grab take a pause right there so i
can grab this specific quote and talk
and we'll dive a little bit deeper into
what i mean by spoke to mankind in their
dreams
so that should be
right here so this is just this is a
quote from the call of cthulhu
and i'll just i'll read this for you
guys
so at some point in the call of cthulhu
we encounter a cult
um they're dancing in the woods
worshiping an idol
uh and one and this is basically what we
learned from this cult
they worshipped so they said the great
old ones
who lived ages before there were any men
and who came to the young world from out
of the sky
those old ones were gone now inside the
earth and under the sea
but their dead bodies had told their
secrets in dreams to the first men
who formed a cult which had never died
this
was that cult
this was that cult and the prisoner said
it had always existed and always
would exist hidden in distant waste and
dark places all over the world
until the time came when the great
priest cthulhu from under his dark house
and the mighty city of relay under the
waters would rise again to bring the
earth
again beneath his sway all right
so they spoke to the first men
in dreams all right and you know there's
there's a lot of stuff
um a lot of people
believe that a lot of human ideas
like sudden ideas that you have
originate in dreams
right that is uh like like like as
though you're like pulling it from like
some kind of
ethereal realm well we know that in in
the body of hp lovecraft
this is certainly true right so the gods
spoke to the first men and they
inspired the formation of this cult this
religion
and they showed the men
where their idols were they they
they they guided them to the idols that
they could worship before the idols that
the gods brought from the stars and they
gave them to them and they said
bow before us and one day one day when
the stars are right
you can awaken us right and it says
specifically
that there were certain arts that would
awaken the gods so it wouldn't just
happen
that is the purpose of the cult
essentially the church of the starry
wisdom yada yada yada
it is to when the stars align
when the stars are right they would be
the ones that were ready
to awaken the great old ones right and
this is the way it worked for for many
many eons while while humanity developed
developed with this cult
secretly doing their dark dark works
right
the gods speaking to them in their
dreams influencing them
teaching them but then something
happened one day
and we don't know why there was never
given an explanation to why this
happened
one day the great city relay
inexplicably sank
beneath the waves
and there's another quote that i gotta
read because it's really really good
it's really really good because
something something essential was loss
lost when the city sank
hmm
if i could just find it here we go
here we go so relay sunk into the waves
in the elder times chosen men had talked
with the entombed old ones in dreams
but then something had happened the
great stone city relay with its
monoliths
and i don't even i don't know how to say
that word hp lovecraft it's some kind of
architectural term that i won't even
bother butchering
monoliths and you know obelisk and stuff
like that
the great stone city of relay had sunk
beneath the waves
and the deep waters full of the one
primal mystery
through which not even thought can pass
had cut off
the spectral intercourse so
something about the ocean something
about the nature of the ocean
blocked the gods spectral intercourse
with mankind and they could no longer
communicate
and let's pause and go all the way back
and i gotta say thank you to
xy tech for sending me the super chat
thank you so much
10 super chat um super interesting so
far man
thank you so thank you dave uh just
a dream thank you so much for your super
chat as well
and thank you guys so much for watching
me if you're enjoying the stream so far
hit the like button
um and also the best way to support this
channel is through the paypal.me link in
the description thank you so guys thank
you guys so much for being here
now moving on we were just and actually
we just gotta i just did get a paypal
from mark williams
thank you so much mark williams for your
15 pay pal
all right so where were we we were
talking about relay sinking beneath the
waves
so when i was the more i think about
let's just pause here before we talk
about
what that means and what happened after
that and maybe why it happened and all
that jazz
definitely i want to talk about this
lovecraft
was definitely a huge fan of uh
the work or not the work he was
definitely a huge fan of atlantis miss
right and actually in the call of
cthulhu and i'm not gonna be able to
find this right now he actually mentions
a specific historical work which talks
about
the atlantis myth right so you have this
great city relay sinking beneath the
waves inexplicably and disappearing
um and this this is also um kind of an
idea that's repeated in the mountains of
madness which i also covered not exactly
a sunken city
but a hidden city a hidden ancient city
of great technology and great mystery
mystery that kind of is forgotten and
lost to time
so right so he was definitely a fan of
those types of ideas which i find
um endlessly compelling
all right so um
anyway the ocean the ocean the ocean so
lovecraft calls
the sea the ocean a great
primal mystery which even the realm of
thought
couldn't penetrate right not even the
old ones could speak
at least not to men through the ocean
right
but the memory the memory of them
was never lost the cult members
they had the sculptures they had the
idols that
the gods had brought with them from
the stars they had the wisdom that had
been passed down and gathered
they had the necronomicon which had been
written by the mad arab abdul what thing
that which is a whole another story
we're not going to talk about the
necronomicon right yet i do got a copy
of the necronomicon right here but we're
not going to get into that just yet
so the information the knowledge of the
old ones
was never never lost it was never never
lost and the cult knew that one day
one day the stars would realign
and they would be there to awaken the
great old ones
and the old ones would continue their
dominion
of earth all right so i got a super chat
uh looking forward to your novel thank
you your team
and mods for all the hard work on your
channel cheers uh thank you so much for
your super chat and thank you so much
for watching
so much so much for watching now i
mentioned earlier
that there are there are the great old
ones
um
and really really the great old ones
actually
refers to
i think a greater body of beings that
are than the ones that are bound
and relay on earth right but it's also
it's a little bit inconsistent because
we'd like to talk about lovecraft's
shared universe but like i don't know if
he was it's not like super meticulous
like some other people shared universe
like
so there's there's a few discrepancies
right
but we can imagine that um the great old
ones that are bound on earth
um are not all of them there are other
ones that exist in other places
beyond the stars um in other dimensions
and other places
these are the specific ones that are
bound to earth and i talked about in the
beginning about there being beings that
were
like them but separate from them all
right so
let's pull up the call of cthulhu again
because there's a great example of such
there's two examples of such beings
mentioned in the call of cthulhu
uh they mention my song of ice and fire
buddies will get a kick out of this one
there's of course the deep ones
and you can see the deep ones here and
the sleeping cthulu
dead dreaming in his house that relay so
the deep ones
they're not mortal they're not gods
they're some kind of
in between and then also in
the call of cthulhu the other beings
that are mentioned which i find
really really cool are these winged bat
monsters
right so there's a section in the call
of cthulhu
when our main character is doing
research about
the cult and cthulhu and his origins and
what this
is um we learned about
a time somewhere i think it was in south
america
there was all this ruckus there were the
the the
the uh local people have had called the
cops and they said someone has to come
and help because
there's a crazy cult out in the forest
somewhere and they've been
kidnapping people wild screams have been
heard
we don't know what's going on so they go
up here and what they see
there's another good art here that i got
to show you it's really cool
and by the way this is i mentioned this
book too this is
behringer's hp lovecraft fully
illustrated
this is what they find
they are dancing singing
chanting in this flame circle
and there's a stone pillar in the center
and at the very top at the very top is a
tiny
tiny sculpture of cthulu
now the cult kept the old ways
you know it is said when the when the
old ones rose you would you'd be to tell
when they were coming
because the earth would fall into
madness where every every person would
just revel in their own pleasure and
violence murder and death and sex and
everything would just be
wild and crazy killing each other and
just wild seeking of pleasure and
craziness and that would be when
the time the cult kept those ways but
always
in secret in twisted dark shadowy
corners of the world so this is unique
why are they doing this here why are
they doing this now well you learn
at some point another type of being had
come up
and kind of talked to the cult communed
with them
and it says these dark winged
spirits of earth had come up from
the deepest darkest forgotten caverns
within the earth
from from beneath forgotten seabeds
and flown up to speak of dark twisted
rumors of things to come
so in my opinion although it's not said
straight up in the call of cthulhu
these bat winged creatures came to the
cult
to tell them that the old ones were
waking up again because they knew it and
they could feel it the stars were
lying again um and as actually said um
in the call cathedral the cult members
they don't take responsibility for all
the deaths they actually say that
it was the winged things that did that
it was the winged things that made those
sacrifices
um and there's also another being that's
mentioned very briefly
and here some kind of
strange ancient entity
that lived at the bottom of a lake
and this is what the bat winged things
worshipped and they said
to look upon the thing was death now
that seems different somehow from the
great old ones it seems like the old
ones
are really really bound to the alignment
of the stars and there's something else
here
so that's what i mean there's various
entities
from the winged bat things to whatever
that strange
entity is that lived at the bottom of
the link to
cthulhu um
so yeah uh
so where we i missed a few super chat so
i gotta go back and get all of these and
then we'll
get to talking about some other things
and then i'll check the paypal to make
sure
i got everything there uh so brent
gordon says this is my entry to
lovecraft other than cthulhu from south
park thanks and i love your content
quinn
thank you so much for being here with me
thanks everyone that's watching right
now i love you guys so much
i'm always down to talk about some
horror horror is my favorite genre
there's something about horror
specifically cosmic horror
that really really just i find very very
intriguing and we'll get in
a little bit more until like what the
actual definition of cosmic horror is
in a minute after i get these super
chats i seem to make a note of that
because cosmic horror is something that
lovecraft
certainly popularized but it's something
that's used in a lot of other
bodies of work a lot of people use
cosmic horror now
um and i have a few examples of that
that i want to talk about as well
okay so reaver 45 says i love your style
quinn keep up with the good work thank
you so much reaper 45
i'm glad that you guys are joining me
thank you for your super chat
uh 21st century afro publishing
i love your name uh my brother i have
been following you for years now since
ice and fire days you inspired
a lot of my reading habits especially
fantasy and sci-fi well thank you so
much for
sticking with me and joining me and
listening to me ramble on about
different books and it's greatly
appreciated
um 45-ish hello uh says hi
thank you says hi found you via dune and
stayed for lovecraft well thank you so
much
lots lots and lots and lots more people
have been telling me that
recently that they found my channel
because of dune and stayed for other
things
that's really really awesome because i
plan on continuing to cover
as i said more lovecraft because i have
like all of this work
i've read almost all of his stories at
this point um
and there's a lot there's a lot to be
talked about so
we're gonna continue down this lovecraft
train as the channel continues and as i
continue to develop and
grow and diverse might diversify my
channel so nate craig thank you for your
super chat as well
thanks for streaming on my birthday
happy birthday nate making it
inadvertently one of the most
interesting to date i love your work so
keep it up well that's that's very very
flattering
the fact of me streaming is making your
birthday more interesting that's
that's really really epic um and i think
that's all the super chats i get right
now
we're gonna real quick check paypal
and looks like we do got some more here
to just look at real quick
apps on phones are so annoying sometimes
guys right so right after i get these
last two we're going to start talking
about cosmic horror
and what exactly cosmic horror is and
what it means
so i got a paypal from james bo
i can't say names guys you know what the
deal is thank you so much james for your
10
paypal and thank you so much chris as
well for your 10
paypal it is greatly appreciated um
internet don't slow up now uh james says
just discover the channel
love the dune content and enjoying the
stream thank you so much
james uh did chris say anything
chris didn't leave a message did mark
say anything i didn't check before
okay thank you guys so much all right
moving on moving on
all right cosmic horror
cosmic horror let's talk about cosmic
ray
so cosmic horror is the horror of
essentially the unknown but in the sense
of
the universe and you know what is
waiting
out there in the dark what what what's
at least the dune quote what senses do
we like that we cannot see a hidden
world all around us
you know what was here before us what
will be here after us
what is here right now that we can't
interpret
or experience and see does it care about
us
is it a danger to us it's the fear of
not
knowing right what lovecraft does very
effectively
is he kind of
he likes to he implies he implies the
mystery
he implies the terror but he rarely
rarely ever shows it
directly in fact the call of cthulhu is
what the call of cthulhu is one of the
only examples where you actually see
like
an old one in its form take a true form
and like just be there on earth
it's usually just the implication of
what could happen
and that's ultimately where cthulhu ends
at right it's
when they come it will be terrible
right and it's also the mystery of what
do they do
when they come so we talked about the
cult right
you might ask yourself what exactly does
the colts have to gain
from worshipping the old ones well
exactly right uh it's kind of it's kind
of twisted right
it's you would imagine that certain
certain
they've been promised certain things
they believe they can gain
power and it's also mentioned that
there's different divisions in the cult
uh the sect of the cult that i actually
just showed you from this book that
appears in the call of cthulhu
is actually mentioned to be a separate
form of the cult
there is the main part of the cult that
exists somewhere
i think in the middle east somewhere in
the desert
actually and which is the main part of
the cult and that is the actual part of
the quote that is in possession
of the original necronomicon which was
written by the mad arab
um so you might ask yourself what are
they having to gain from it
um i don't know
but i mean i imagine that they think
they have something to gain
but in reality the old ones
the gods what is a human to them except
for
but a method to escape the god the gods
the gods didn't
whisper to the first spin in their
dreams because oh we want to make
friends it's not like
it's not like the christian god where
it's like i create a bunch of things
because i want i want
something to to love me it's it's the
gods just want to be free
to do whatever it is that they do and to
revel in whatever things that they do
and humans are a mere insignificant
speck
right when when these things return
when cthulhu wakes up he is here to
reshape
the earth reshape the world in his image
whatever that image is
and the fact that we don't and the fact
that the fact that we can't see clearly
what that image is is terrifying
and then also the idea that
our dominion our quote-unquote dominion
over the earth
is tremendously fragile at any point
something that is
that is that is more ancient than
anything that we can even conceive and
more intelligent than anything that we
can conceive and more powerful than
anything that we could conceive could
just come and just
destroy us immediately so that that is
that is i guess
the gist of cosmic core the gist of
cosmic core the things
the idea that there's things beyond us
things beyond our control that are
malevolent
and not even malevolent often just kind
of indifference because indifference
a morality is just as bad like the same
way
you carelessly swat a mosquito
right are you you're not you're not
consciously thinking let me murder this
mosquito
let me smack this mosquito and murder it
you think oh it's kind of annoying flick
that is essentially how the great old
ones
would see humanity oh it's kind of
annoying flick
um and so throughout the body of work
when you have you have
different characters that piece together
certain pieces of information
um there are old ones the existence of
these beings
and oftentimes their minds are broken
especially if they stare directly into
the abyss and this is a good
point to talk about um nietzsche said if
you stare into the abyss
the abyss stares back at you and
lovecraft took that to heart
because one of the um this is a trope
now but this
this is something that lovecraft pretty
much invented um
you stare into the face
of an old one you stare into the face of
infinity something you can't
understand or comfort him something that
is beyond you and it breaks your mind
the appears the abyss stares back into
your soul
right that happens in the mountains of
madness you see uh
they escape that terrible city and that
thing
that was there that we don't know but
one character looks back
and he loses his sanity right that
happens in the call of cthulhu
they escape the the relay in the end
they
they sail away one guy looks back and
he loses his mind um so i mentioned
in the mountains of madness too the the
biblical story
of lot and his wife um so everyone knows
the story of sodom and gomorrah
it's kind of a wild crazy story if you
think about it but that's not the point
um basically the cities were destroyed
and god said don't look back
do not look back lot's wife looked back
and was turned into a pillar of salt um
so in the same way
we see that in so many lovecraft stories
and it's become a trope
like stephen king used it in it a bunch
like you have the the one bully
character that stares to the dead lights
and goes crazy
or uh uh
bill's wife stares stares at its true
form
without any of the mass and she sees it
just
as it is and she goes crazy because it's
certain like
so that that's another element of cosmic
horror we like to think as humans that
we can know any anything we can
understand anything we just
if we just acquire enough knowledge
if we could only have enough knowledge
we could we could figure anything out
but lovecraft says no no there are
things
that are beyond your little minds to
even
conceive and i i can't help
that this is this is me speaking i can't
help but think
that that has to be true right i can't
help but think
and believe that there are things in our
universe and in our reality
that are so complex and so just
beyond that our minds can't think
can't comprehend it right we're
conscious beings yes but we're really
just like little
we're little monkeys with like little
squishy wet brains
and the universe is a vast
vast vast vast vast place
infinite darkness in all directions and
who knows what's out there
right um so me and dave actually
lml we actually just watched a doctor
who episode which is like
probably one of my favorite doctor
episodes called midnight right and
definitely some lovecraftian elements
here so he's on this
planet and before this planet was kind
of colonized they built like a resort
there or something before that
no one had ever even been in the system
they've just been
circling around a lonely star since the
dawn of time no life
nothing nothing but there is something
there
and whatever it is it's it's it's it's
unlike anything that could ever have
existed so the point is
you you have certain you have certain
characters in the episode that reject
the idea that anything could exist
because they're so grounded to like the
sense of
what they know they're like no life is
this
life is this this is what life is life
has these characteristics
but what do we really know life could
take endless forms
like life could take forms beyond our
conceptualization or
understanding right um so that was that
was i guess the key point of that one of
the themes of that
doctor who episode and that's also a
lovecraftian idea that we don't really
understand and maybe we can't even
understand
oh right guys
so yeah that's that what are you guys
saying in the chat before we get into
the next section
you guys enjoying the stream so far what
do you guys think so far
so do i got any um any of you guys new
to lovecraft
so i know a few of you guys said this
was your intro to lovecraft
but yeah let's just um ask to chat real
quick how many of you guys have read the
work of lovecraft before
or i know i know you've heard of him
you're watching the stream but have any
of you like read some of the stories
what are some of your favorite stories i
would probably say my favorites are
the call of cthulhu which is a short
story um if you're going to read the
call of cthulhu i would
i definitely recommend this one
behringer illustrated on every page
brings it to life in a new way also the
dunwich horror is a really good one
mountains of madness is a really good
one the color of the color out of space
is a great short story
so yeah so everyone's so something a lot
of people saying
they haven't read it some people saying
they have
currently reading it nope this is my
intro says mod mary awesome
someone says i finished at the mountains
of madness today
cool see mountains of madness is
definitely an excellent one and like i
said you can check out my video on that
one
um yeah cause like i really really like
the idea of like something being hidden
on earth
that we haven't discovered and that was
something that
it's kind of an idea that you can only
play with and kind of the time in which
lovecraft was playing with these ideas
is kind of the latest
time like the 1920s because right now
we've explored everything
so i like the idea of like if you're
going to tell these types of stories
like take it back a couple hundred years
when like
when we hadn't explored everything um
lovecraft very
and smartly put that tail in it in
arnica like a very remote place that
we don't know we didn't know a lot about
then and still kind of there's mysteries
but yeah done which horror the doom that
came to sarnoff someone said really
really good one
uh mountains of madness downwards horror
i really like as well uh
dream quest for unknown kada
uh dream quest for unknown kadaf is an
excellent lovecraft story
so a lot of people don't like horror
like horror
um which i understand i understand but
dream quest for unknown kadat is
actually a pretty interesting lovecraft
story
and i actually have here i think a
graphic
novel version of dream quest so this is
um
a lovecraft book that i had this is
drawn by colbert
cool bird i hope i'm saying that right
this is a graphic novel adaptation of
four lovecraft stories and one of them
is dream quest for unknown doc and the
reason that i like this story a lot is
because it's not
really a horror story it's kind of like
a twisted
fairy tale fantasy story about this guy
that goes on a quest through his streams
he's looking for this golden city
and oh it's such a trippy definitely
some spooky parts but yeah
i get the sense what i wanted to get to
was the weird
way the story just kind of
flows like a dream is very reminiscent
of well not even i can't say that's
wrong context
i should say i'm gonna mention neil
gaiman sandman is what i'm getting to
i definitely think that neil gaiman was
influenced by dream quest for unknown
kadath
because the dreamy way that his stories
flow in sandman
it's just like this just the weirdness
of it the mystery of it
just just brilliant that's one of my
favorite stories for sure
the shadow over inn's mouth that's a
really good one
that's a really good one
deep ones man the deep ones the deep
ones are endlessly interesting too i
know a lot of my song of ice and fire
people really get into the deep ones
and actually me and lml are going to do
a stream on euron
and the deep ones and all of that
lovecraft the song about our stuff
at some point it's really really cool
because george r martin is someone that
definitely loves definitely loves
lovecraft
he uses a lot of lovecraft language i
was just reading that passage earlier in
the stream about the first men
and the gods whispering their secrets to
the first men in dreams
it almost sounds like that could come
right out of a song of ice and fire it's
pretty freaking amazing
it's pretty freaking amazing uh let's
see i got a super chat real quick and
i'll check my paypal right after this as
well
and by the way guys the best way to
support quinn's ideas to support this
channel
is through paypal because youtube super
chats are a little wonky they take like
huge percentages
but everything is greatly appreciated
dawn now people says have you read
lovecraft country or seen the show
premiere
it peaked my interest and i like your
thoughts if you have i have not read it
i said in the beginning of the stream
that i have not read love crowd country
i'm going to read it as soon as i can
i'm gonna head down to barnes noble and
get my copy of it i've heard the
synopsis
i'm very very intrigued by lovecraft
country um so basically it's about it
takes place in the civil rights era
and you've got like a black sci-fi nerd
guy which like oh it's me
and there's lovecraft stuff happening
and he's like realizing it because he's
like a fan of
oh so that's definitely like something i
i get into for sure
so i'm looking forward to reading that
book and then later watching the show
first
for sure um all right so someone says i
found cthulhu playing dungeons and
dragons in 1981
is that a thing you can you can cthulhu
and dungeons and dragons i've never
played dungeons and dragons i don't know
what it's all about
but that's real cool danica sent me to
see you and i never
left thank you for your work oh that's
awesome i love danica
come up a girl 19 ah she got me into
dune she's awesome i love danica
and real quick let me just check
to make sure that
i didn't miss anything on paypal because
it doesn't send me a notification
always refresh all right and
looks like we are good all right we are
going to move on
so let's talk about i said i was going
to talk about
some people that have been influenced by
lovecraft now i really enjoyed in my
last stream
aw dang i don't have that book over here
right back i'll be right back
so
all right guys
alrighty already already so we were
talking about
george r martin and how he was
influenced by lovecraft but as i was
saying
i'm going to do a stream with lml at
some point we're going to get into the
nitty-gritty of all that
but i want to talk about someone else
that has been
very influenced by the work of lovecraft
that is stephen king
stephen king loves lovecraft and it's
of course he would the greatest stephen
king is in my opinion the greatest
modern horror author
like period i'm sorry if you don't agree
but that's my opinion so
it's amazing to me and i love the fact
and it's of course the greatest modern
author would love
you know one of the greatest uh horror
authors of all time
so let's talk about it because i talk
about it in my last stream and a lot of
people really liked it so
in stephen king's book it this being
which in the movies and john they always
it's always a clown
which the clown is one of the forms that
it takes but that's not what it is
this thing is a cosmic
being of has
i don't even know how to describe it um
and even though it is defeated in the
book i mean it's not
it's not even clear whether it seems to
me
honestly that in it what happens is
the children banish the form the
physical form that it took on earth but
it definitely still exists somewhere
else and like a realm of thought
or something it lives as stephen king
says there's
there's just a lot of hints that it's
still alive anyway
this thing it that the children
eventually referred to as
it came to earth just like a
lovecraftian god
from beyond right it came from beyond
millions of years ago sound familiar
before humanity ever got there sound
familiar and it waited
it waded beneath the earth and dreamed
and when and when and when men finally
came to earth
it called them to its place and the town
dairy
was formed and this was a town
that was shaped in this creature's image
it was this
it was this creature's killing pin so
essentially what we have here in stephen
king's work is a lovecraftian
eldridge horror that is waiting
and dreaming and communicating
in the language of thought in the exact
same way as the great old ones and love
drops works too
so it is essentially stephen king's
lovecraft take
i mean a lot of his books have those
elements but this is one
where it really sticks out to me and of
course there's a lot of that in the dark
tower series
it shows up all over the place
essentially i've been reading um even
even something like a
stephen king's 11 22 63
you can see the lovecraft influence the
fear of the unknown the fear of
what is waiting you know so yeah stephen
king
so much lovecraft influence and i
absolutely love it
and then also what i like what stephen
king does
that lovecraft didn't do and i talked
about this last time
is that stephen king wasn't afraid to
he he knows exactly how to give away the
right amount of details about the being
right so there are sections in it where
you're inside of this
thing's head this lovecraftian
entity you're inside of its head right
and so obviously it's thoughts and it's
the way it thinks is very very very
strange
and very very very very just odd and
weird and it's thinking about
how it had always been
and what what the the thing that stands
out about the monster the creature
so much is it it's arrogance it thinks i
have always been i cannot i cannot be
hurt
i've been here since the dawn of time
these humans are nothing to me
but it is it's also feeling emotions for
the first time and it's
angry it's angry it's angry because the
children made
it fear it so it's really interesting to
see
how an eldritch horror reacts to
feeling fear for the first time to
feeling pain
for the first time it's a really
interesting idea and that's the thing
about
a lot of people throw around the word
copying like oh so and so copied this
guy and did this guy and that's true
sometimes
but this is this is how you stephen king
that's how you you're inspired by
someone and then you like expand upon
the idea
because lovecraft would have never done
that right lovecraft would have never
taken you inside of the head
of the creature right but stephen king
did and it was still scary and i think
that's for that
that the stephen king will ever be a
master
stephen king will ever forever be a
master what is the key about
it's the key to my heart baby you want
it somebody somebody gets it
i'm just kidding all right guys just
take a pause right there
thanks everyone for watching we've got
like 600 people watching guys so if
you're enjoying the stream so
far please hit the like button and um
yeah and subscribe if you're not already
subscribed
um if you want to support me and support
this channel
you can send in a donation of any amount
is accepted to the paypal.me link in the
description it's greatly
appreciated and you can send me like a
message and i'll read it out on the
stream ask me a question
whatever and yeah just thinks someone
says imitation is the highest form of
flattery
a lot lots of times as well
stephen oh someone says stephen king
said that randall flagg in the stand was
niall at the tap
i didn't know he said that but that is
like
that is that's so true and that now that
i think about it so randall flagg is a
character
the dark man he has many different names
he shows up in stephen king
king's work and he's always interacting
with humans like sewing doing lots of
awful
evil stuff um nyarlathotep
in lovecraft's body of work is the only
one of the
elder beings that can be called
an old one that communes with
humankind on a regular basis and even
walks among them
um walks among them at certain times so
uh
niall at the table he appears in a bunch
of different stories he actually appears
in
the one i just mentioned which is uh the
dream quest for unknown kadath in fact
huh that's a good one actually
um i won't spoil exactly what happens in
the end of dream quest for unknown
qadhaf but he appears in that one and
yeah
he's just kind of like a trickster he's
kind of like a trickster
if you wanted to make a comparison think
it think of him as like
the peter baelish almost of uh
of lovecraft's body of work right but of
course
obviously peter baelish is not a god
is not literally not now like that but
yeah you can think of him that way
another super chat thank you so much
travis hammer
have you read king's short story
jerusalem's lot it's a prequel to salem
sly and explain
explains why the town is evil which
attracted the vampire it was his most
lovecraftian story i've never read
jerusalem's lot oh my god that's
something i need to get on i have
a salem slot is so scary and i love it
jerusalem fly is a good one for sure
to read that's on my list for sure
actually i've actually been on a huge
stephen king
kick because i've just been like
re-getting into like a lot of this
recent work and like really like
rediscovering him again and yeah he's
always loved lovecraft and it's all
there
okay
someone says i think nobody told bayliss
that exactly yeah
someone says unknown is extremely
difficult to read translated in spanish
yeah i don't i don't i i'm not i'm not a
person that speaks multiple languages so
i wouldn't know
but like yeah that's a thing too that's
why i highly recommend
this book this has let me um see which
stories this one has in it specifically
because when it comes to like
adaptations of lovecraft's works even
like graphic novel adaptations some of
them are bad
and i'll give you an example of a bad
one which books i wish
it told me which specific stores this
this one has this one
this one has at the mountains of madness
it has dream quest
for a kadath it's got
it's got a few of the popular ones i
can't it's not the pages are marked for
some reason it's annoying
but yeah check this out if uh
where am i getting at yeah lovecraft
likes to use weird words
and it's kind of hard to read sometimes
if you're not like used to it
so check out this adaptation of coolberg
right this is a i think this book was
like 15 20 bucks on amazon or something
and it's actually like a graphic novel
interpretation of some of his most
popular stories and there's like four or
five of them in there
then also i can't recommend enough um
the call of cthulhu by
the bearing traversion of call of
cthulhu fully illustrated
this this like
it brings a whole new life to the story
i look at it all the time this is my
preferred method of like
absorbing the story at this point so
yeah it's full page art so it definitely
helps the story like
flow and like just go and make a lot
more sense
for those of you that might not be as
familiar or adapted to reading
lovecraft's uh writing style
andreas gillo says some words just can't
be translated yeah i imagine that is the
case i imagine that is the case
so it looks like i got a paypal
from keith adkins thank you so much
keith
greatly appreciated and another paypal
also from
let's see let's see let's see
from thomas kelly thank you so much
thomas kelly for your paypal
um so thanks everyone that has sent in
donations it's greatly appreciated
this was a nice recommended stream
ecobear says thank you so much
um do i have people here that are new to
the channel is my stream
actually getting circulated around the
place um
yeah so like like i was saying earlier
this stream is basically
it's a prelude to a lot more livecraft
work that i'm
going to be doing on this channel i've
always been a fan of the work of
lovecraft and some of you that have been
watching me for years know that because
i always mention him
in relation to other stories um
especially a song of ice and fire
there's even elements of lovecraft's
work in dune
right the great entity right that the
great enemy i mean
that the honor montrez ran away from so
in dune
you have humans going out into deep
space and then
at some point they all run backwards and
it's like why are you guys what are you
running from and it's some kind of
great entity a great enemy that they're
running away from that they cannot
mess this thing is so deadly whatever it
is we gotta run away
so yeah i'm not gonna say what that is
because i have ideas about what it is
but like
the mystery of it is very lovecraftian
the idea that there's something waiting
what is out there what is out there
so that's just really great so welcome
welcome
new guys new guys oh wait so we got a
lot of new people that's super super
awesome
uh please subscribe please like and you
know comment on the stream afterwards
welcome all welcome all someone says i
have been subscribed for years
all right welcome all the noobs all of
you are
greatly appreciated um
let's see oh yeah i was gonna mention
yeah i said i said i forgot to do this
i was gonna say there are good
adaptations of lovecraft's work in
graphic novel form
but i gotta hate a little bit all right
so
the call of cthulhu a graphic novel dark
tales
adapted by dave shepard
look dave shepard look dave shepard we
need to talk
what is this this is awful all right
look
i don't know what this is supposed to be
but this is not the call of cthulhu
um
just uh just uh like if you if you like
yeah i said i was
i want to make sure don't buy this one
if you see this one and you're thinking
like
oh let me go like read call the cthulhu
in a graphic novel form it'll be cool
please don't do it
i don't know whose idea this was but
it's like they've taken the call of
cthulhu which is one of the most
terrifying hp lovecraft stories
and they've turned it into almost like a
kid book
it's like a kid book and they've added
like these other plot lines
and like added like different points of
view and it's just really really
really really not great not well done
not well done in the slightest
um so yeah avoid this one i'm sorry dave
shepard
but please don't make any more of these
stop
screwing around with the work of
lovecraft this was not scary at all
they removed anything that could have
made it even slight that made it even
slightly scary or edgy
it's like all of the the mystery is gone
and even like the way that it's
even just the the art style just sucks
it's not scary
ugh just trash and it's like
when you have a story like the call of
cthulhu right and i was saying this to
dave my roommate
when you have a story like the call of
cthulhu that has survived the test of
time
for so there's a reason that people
still talk about that short story
because it's terrifying and it's good
you read it and you're immediately
captivated
you're immediately compelled it's it's
good
you don't need to change it you don't
need to add an extra plots you don't
need to make it
yeah i'm doing i'm doing a very in-depth
video
on the call of cthulhu that's my next
major work that i'm going to put out
but basically let's talk about that one
a little bit because i wanted to say
this earlier
because i i always say this is the one
if i had to recommend any story
of causal will get in immediately it's
this one because
everything about lovecraft that makes
him famous and essential
is take is in this story the idea
of the waiting evil gods it takes place
um the fear of the unknown is there um
looking into the abyss
into the abyss and going mad it's in
there
um just the fear of
just just everything that makes
lovecraft famous is here the colts
mention of the necronomicon it is
absolutely the essential body of work
and yeah
it should not be messed with and shame
on dave shepard
shame on dave shepard shame on you so
someone says
arkham asylum in batman was inspired by
lovecraft that's really cool
that's really really cool so i should
talk about this
a film that i watched that was
definitely lovecraft inspired
recently well not even recently like i
would say like well within the last
couple of years
was a movie called annihilation right
and
it was think color out of space and
actually we will talk
we're gonna talk okay look remind me
guys after i talk about annihilation to
talk about
color out of space the lovecraft
adaptation all right we're going to talk
about that one
but first let's get into annihilation
because a good movie versus the bad
movie
so annihilation right you have something
that lands from the stars and then we
don't know what it is
mute tastes everything around it just we
don't understand it
people are going mad when they are near
it it's crazy
um some kind of entity is there um and
it's affecting everything around it
it's really really good so that's a
recommendation of like a lovecraft idea
that was kind of well done then we have
the color out of space right and
i have to say i'm sorry but a lot of my
audience recommended this color out of
space film to me
if you don't know the color out of space
is one of lovecraft's most
it's one of his most famous short
stories you have
something falling out of the sky and you
have a guy that's called to investigate
it and he's found that like
the people have gone mad it's like
affected the plants and the animals and
it's just really really scary
um the movie not so much
all right so i gotta let me get this
super chat real quick and uh
monk is most says imprisoned with
pharaohs is my favorite lovecraft story
and harry houdini inspired parts of it
found you through angie speaks thanks oh
angie
is a great friend of mine but anyway
i i have no idea how you can take
the color out of space such a cool
weird lovecraft story and make it so
unbelievably not scary
and just plotless it's like that's
that's the thing that like
you always know what the with okay if
you're gonna make a movie if you're
gonna take a short story the color out
of space and adapt it
make it like a quiet mystery
that's like dark i don't need this like
goofy family dynamic with like
nicholas cage screaming about alpacas
oh my god it was so stupid it ripped off
every single horror movie that i
could could think of it ripped off the
thing it ripped off
carrie it ripped off every horror trope
imaginable
and it didn't even have it didn't even
have
the essential parts of lovecraft's work
that make him so scary
right so you have you it opens up you've
got like the daughter character she's
like a witch or something
and at some point she's like opening up
like a necronomicon book for dummies or
something and she's like doing some kind
of incantation
and like carving like a pentagram into
her chest you think okay she's gonna
awaken
some kind of eldritch monster and it's
going to take over and if this is where
it gets good this is where like
the movie kicks off but nothing happens
literally the result of her like ritual
was nothing
and then you have like the mom character
and the son character
who get combined together and like they
become like a weird thing monster and
they start flapping
it's that's not lovecraftian where
where's where's the
where's the waiting entity like where's
the sense of
of coming dread where's the where's the
scent where's the sense
okay look i think i think this is what i
need to say in lovecraft's work
one of the things that makes it very
very very very scary
is the idea that there is
intelligent malevolence just waiting
to pounce right and that is one thing
that this movie did not have at all
right it was just like confusing
plotless and stupid nicholas cage
screaming about a bunch of alpaca what
was the point of the alpacas like what
was the alpaca thing i just don't even
know
that was awful why did you recommend it
to me it was terrible
it wasn't the color out of space it was
stupid i hated it
i just had to get that one off my chest
guys i don't know how any of you liked
it it was just bad
it's bad and i i think that if i didn't
know what lovecraft was and i had never
watched or heard any lovecraft
and then i i watched the nicholas cage
color out of space movie
i wouldn't want to i wouldn't want to
read any love crap because i
if the rest of the work is that bad and
that terrible then uh
and then at the very best even if you
like remove
it being a lovecraft thing even if it
wasn't a lovecraft thing the movie
itself
was bad the characters no depth
the development did not exist totally
inconsistent
and then nothing made sense in the end
and it was just dumb
all right so that is my review of the
color out of space the film
i give it a like a two out of two two
out of ten
all right so i got another super chat
thank you so much for your super chat uh
pompous altmer i always wanted to get
into lovecraft but i never knew where to
start
what would be a good book to start out
with by the way i love your channel keep
quinn keep up the good work
well as i keep mentioning i've mentioned
this a few times in the stream
i absolutely think that if you are new
to lovecraft and you want to
start off just on one story to get you
in call of cthulhu if the call of
cthulhu does not hook you
i don't know what will all right we're
just gonna let's open it up
i actually even just like the first the
first part of call of cthulhu was so
good
uh listen this
i'm just gonna read you the opening
paragraph
of call of cthulhu right listen to this
the most merciful thing in the world i
think is the inability
of the human mind to correlate all its
contents
we live on a placid island of ignorance
in the midst of black seas of infinity
and it was not meant that we should
voyage far
the sciences each straining in its own
direction
have hitherto harmed us little but
someday the piecing together of
dissociated knowledge
will open up such terrifying vistas of
reality
and of and of our frightful position
therein
that we shall either go mad from the
revelation or
flee from the deadly light into the
peace and safety
of a new dark age
so right there he's talking about
there are mysteries there are secrets
in the world that are so great and so
unnerving that
the idea of them being them being public
knowledge would
destroy civilization i mean you think
you think that might be out there like
oh
there's nothing that we could find
certain proof of that would destroy
civilization and send humans kind
yes it could right let's say if we
discovered one day
beyond a shadow of a doubt right just
like 100
proven that there was like a giant
monster like the size of 12 jupiters
surrounding the earth in another
dimension
and it was about to eat us in like 50
years and we knew that yeah the id the
thought of that being
the truth would probably destroy
civilization and destabilize everything
so it's best that we shouldn't even know
it
so it's that's that's one of the ideas
too it's like the idea like
there's certain things that are so bad
that maybe like we shouldn't even know
about it
and maybe that's true to a certain
extent right it's like
um in movies and stuff like whenever
there's like an asteroid headed towards
there they never tell the public
right because it's like oh what are they
gonna do they're just gonna like go
crazy and start looting and whatever
like if we knew that there was there
were monsters and that at any point
they could just come and take us over
almost like i think people would feel
like nothing mattered right
i hear people person i'm an agnostic
right
so i've heard people of faith say to me
some
certain times like oh if there's no like
god
wouldn't you just like go around killing
and murdering i mean i wouldn't
but like the fact that there's people
that would even suggest that is like oh
that's a little weird
so i i certainly think that if if people
thought
oh life is meaningless we're just as
uh the mountains madness suggests we're
just like the residue of like some
old being we're not we're not special at
all i think yeah
certain people would find that very
very very very very very very difficult
to accept and once they did accept it it
would break their
it would break their sense of who they
are break their conceptualizations of
reality it's like um
it's like darwinism it's like it's like
uh
the idea of evolution to some people is
so hard to accept because it takes away
like
humans like to think of themselves as
like the center of like the universe
like the center of everything like god
made us in his image
we are special but lovecraft says no no
no no no you are not special
in fact you're you're you're the
opposite of special you're totally
insignificant
you're like you're scum you are the
residue you weren't even meant to be
creative like you're the residue of like
things that we created to serve us so i
was like so yeah
it goes that deep it goes that deep
i don't even know how i got on that
subject but it's just it's just
oh it just goes in with love absolutely
the people that live inside of rick's
talking rick and morty here
rick's battery has a civilization inside
it that produces electricity
all just to power rick stuff like the
moment that they realize that that's all
they are
of course there's like three layers of
it i guess it's kind of the same right
it is the same it's the horror of
realizing that like
oh this is what life is we're just like
tools or feeding stocks
exactly exactly exactly exactly
so i've got some new paypal donations
thank you guys so much for
continuing to send in your donations
with your messages
so i think i got keith adkins earlier so
thank you again for that
but i got another one from mark
northcott thank you so much mark mark
for your paypal donation and anybody can
send in
one of those and you can leave a message
in the link
in the description wait does it pop up
here i don't know if it pops up or not
okay so mark northcott says on paypal he
says i met frank herbert in the 80s
got a book signed and asked the dumb
question what did you think of the movie
he said too short
or too long i can't remember which
that's pretty freaking funny and that's
a pretty accurate um
interpretation of the of the doing movie
for sure
for sure uh thank you so much for that
mark
all right let's see let's see what else
do we got to mention actually i did want
to show you guys i absolutely wanted to
show you guys another
book that was influenced by lovecraft
but this book in particular
uses the work of lovecraft in a very
very interesting way
so this is a book that i read recently
last year it's called monstrous
and i will just find this page real
quick i should have bookmarked this
before the stream but like
you guys know i i'm so like i'm
scatterbrained
but essentially this is a fantasy world
created by
marjorie liu and sana takeda and
there's a lot there's lots of different
races of beings but at some point
there were the great old ones as they
called them
and these old ones had dominion of the
earth long ago and they still exist on
the earth
in shades right they appear randomly
it's like these these shadowy
apparitions but it doesn't seem as
though you can talk to them
or connect with them in any way and so
in monstrous you have the main
character who is oh here they are
these are their shades and as you can
see this book is beautifully drawn
you see the shades of the of the great
old ones that have
moved on and monstrous they are they're
imprisoned in
another realm of existence but in this
story our main girl
monstrous she's actually bound
to one of these lovecraftian beings
she's bound to it
um and it gives her powers but it also
has to feed it also must consume
so she's constantly needing to consume
and it's very great horror
but at the same time at the same time
and this is what i mean about new
authors being able to come into
these lovecraftian ideas and just take
them to a whole new place
at the same time also what stephen king
is doing
we're introducing these lovecraftian
eligitors but she's also humanizing
them the the one that's attached to our
main character here
is a character in and of itself and it's
so brilliantly done so you can take
these ideas these
the idea of like uh it's it's not it's
not exactly clear in the beginning
there's definitely like the horror of
like trying to figure out what exactly
this thing is
is it evil what is it but yeah once it
unfolds
it's very very very well done very well
done
so again that's another example of
someone taking lovecraftian ideas
doing a whole new twist on it and also
lovecraft isn't the only thing inspired
that that monsters has
monstrous has it's got lord of the rings
it's got a song of ice and fire this is
let me just talk about how good this
book is on top of like being lovecraft
inspired this is one of the best graphic
novels that i have ever read
period monstrous is
well god if tadia could be like even
like
this art can you believe this yeah so
yeah check out monstrous
lovecraft inspired fantasy inspired
great horror
great book great great characters and i
did get a few super chats
while i was talking about monstrous and
the lovecraft influence
that's there so
minch man says you've inspired me to
read dune i've gotten 450 pages in a
week and a half
thanks man that is epic i'm so glad
that i have inspired you to read dune
and i'm so glad that
i inspire you guys to read anything you
know
you know the whole reason that i started
this channel was because
was because i would talk my friends
and people i was dating i would talk
their heads off about fantasy books that
i loved
right it started with a song of ice and
fire when i really started to
re-read a song of ice and fire in my 20s
because i read it very young
i read i think there was like four
three or four books out when i first
started reading a song of ice and fire
when i was very young and then i picked
it up again in my 20s and it like
lit on fire for me in a whole new way
and so i would just talk people's heads
off about it so i was like i gotta start
a youtube channel
and start and talk people about it but
then it of course as you guys can see
we've evolved this channel and we're
doing more things with this channel and
it's doing really really great
and i'm happy that you guys are here
with me and enjoying it with me
good versus evil no lovecraft is more
bacon versus necktie
uh let's let's talk about good versus
evil actually let's talk about that
because that is not that's actually not
something
that lovecraft is dealing with he's it's
not about
it is absolutely not about
good versus evil um
because can you really call them evil
right this entity
any more than humanity as an entity is
evil
right because if you think if you think
of humanity as like an organism
we're we're destroying the earth too
this is like what do you mean like we're
we're totally destroying the earth this
is 130 degrees in death valley
the other day like the the hottest
recorded temperatures
on planet earth they could since like
it's in a really really long time
so um yeah we're destroying the earth
too so it's not about evil it's about
coexistence
um whatever they are um
the way they exist is just just does not
jive
with the way beings like us
exist um and we talked about
what exactly the old ones are made of
they're not made of matter
at least not the same type of matter
that we're made up
of um they're made of something else um
that allows for them to be able to
travel through stars and then also
there's a scene in the call of cthulhu
where where the ship
the ship actually moves through him and
and
it's described as it's almost like
they're moving through like a
gaseous cloud and it smells like
an endless it smells like endless
underwater graves have been opened
just like the most horrible smell you
could imagine as they're moving through
it
and they move through him and he just
comes back together like nothing happens
so he's not
he's not made up of matter in the same
sense that we are whatever he is
it's not like us it's not like us
all right and then also let's talk about
this too because we i didn't get into
this
lovecraft loves to talk about
dreaming gods right and he talks about
their language being the language of
thought
and then he also talks about i said this
earlier he calls cthulhu specifically
the great priest and he talks about
cthulhu spells being the spells that are
the ones that are preserving the old
ones
right so it's his power his spells that
are doing that so i think about dreaming
what is he doing my dreaming
i think cthulhu is just
communing with the ethereal plane doing
something else he's probably
existing somewhere else in some other
form while he's not on earth
because i mentioned stephen king's it as
well and like how i said
i don't believe that the children killed
it whatever it is i think they killed
the physical form that it took while it
was on earth and
it as in the consciousness of it always
would exist
somewhere else but it needed
a physical form it needed a physical
form to exist in if it was going to live
in our dimension that's the thing
so it's kind of like i imagine
the consciousness of these types of
beings
is actually being projected from some
other place
which is why they cannot die right
so so so so when the stars realign
they're not they're not they're not
they're not dead they cannot move
like if you look at if even if you look
at the art because behringer behringer's
art is really good so let me just show
you that
i'll show you barone's art to maybe get
a better example of what i
mean because we see the deep ones
and cthulhu sleeping
see on a girl hey sweetie
yeah please she's just sleeping i'll
give her some
switch come here so you see here that
cthulhu is sleeping
sorry my dog just busted in she's like
i'm tired of hanging out outside i want
to come in it's dark now
all right so you see cthulhu here
sleeping
and you get the sense
like i kind of lost my train of thought
we were talking about consciousness
being projected from another place right
and that uh these physical bodies don't
really
there's these physical forms like what
we see this this
this winged thing with the the tentacles
it's not a it's not actually what he is
whatever he really is
is somewhere else just like
the creature in stephen king's book
whatever he really is
it it is somewhere else
and it just in order to interact with us
in order to
interact with us on a physical plane it
needs a physical body and that's
all there is to it oh girl
all right she'll be quiet she was she's
always going to bark
one time in protest someone says you
always struck me as a bird guy well
there are birds in the house
there's some birds in the house there's
some birds in this house
yeah it's our perception of it yeah
that's the thing
see that's true that's that's the true
thing as well um
perception right perception let's
actually
find the section here
where cthulhu wakes up because he's
actually described in a very very very
very interesting way
as far as his form and as far as what
the men
see when they look upon him so let's do
that and get into that a little bit
let's do that and get into that
because it's really really cool
let's see it's right around here
oh yeah here we go here we go
let's get into this
okay okay here we go here we go so you
have
in call of cthulhu you have this monster
being accidentally awakened by
totally innocent men and so this is this
is what they hear
and see at experience as they stand
on the city of raleigh which has
risen again to the surface the one
sunken city
and they're staring down and into the
depths to this blackness
everyone listened and everyone was
listening still
when it lumbered slobberingly into sight
and gropingly squeezed its gelatinous
immensity through the black doorway
into the into the tainted outside air of
that poison
city of madness so right guys i just
want to tell you
it's it with a capital i
right so it's it so you want to know
where stephen king got it from
there you go baby he refers to cthulhu
right there as
it with a capital i so let's just read
it again
everyone listened and everyone was
listening still when it
lumbered slobberingly into sight and
gropingly squeezed its gelatinous
green immensity through the black
doorway into the tainted outside air of
that poison
city of madness and then it goes on
so this is what i'm reading here i'll
get it in a second what i'm reading here
is um our main character in the call of
cthulhu reading
or trying to interpret what a madman
wrote so let's
just to give you context of what i'm
reading from poor joe hanson's
handwriting almost gave out when he
wrote this
of the six men who never reached the
ship
he thinks two perished of pure fright
so two of the men two of the men
die before they even get to the ship
just from looking at this thing
all right
give me a passage to read while you are
okay yeah yeah yeah keep reading yeah
start with poor johansson there you go
and then continue on to the next page as
well so dave's going to read a little
bit of that section that i was talking
about
oh hello
poor johansson's handwriting almost gave
out when he wrote of this
of the six men who never reached the
ship he thinks two perished of pure
fright in that accursed instant
the thing cannot be described there is
no language for such
abysms of shrieking and immemorial
lunacy
such eldritch contradictions of all
matter force and cosmic order
a mountain walked or stumbled god
what wonder that across the earth a
great architect went mad
and poor wilcox raved with fear that
telepathic instant
the thing of the idols the green sticky
spawn of the stars
had awakened to claim its own the stars
were right again
and what an age old cult had failed to
do by design
a banner of innocent sailors had done by
accident
after the gentillions of years
wait no crap yeah vigintillions of years
great cthulhu was loose again
and ravening for delight all right
that's probably good enough
all right there we go thank you that was
fun i enjoyed that
whoop my colorful shorts yeah peep the
colorful shorts baby
so absolutely you can see
you can see how the creature itself is
described
right they see it but do they really see
it
they see it but they're kind of like
what am i looking at i don't understand
what i'm looking at it's like
it's like a contradiction of like i
don't it's like it's there
but it's not there they're seeing it but
they can't
comprehend it right
um so yeah so let me just go back to
that page
and go over those words again
yeah yeah
oh yeah
you know this would actually make a good
drinking game reading random lovecraft
quotes and seeing like how many stumbles
yeah that vigentillion that
vigentillions word is like
like what yeah see see yeah here
the thing cannot be described there is
no language for such abysms of shrieking
and in more immemorial lunacy such
eldritch contradictions of matter and
force
right again where you think stephen king
got it from
so we see him as this giant
winged thing with tentacles but that's
just
the closest thing that our minds can
come
to interpreting what it is that we're
actually
seeing there is no language to describe
all of the sculptures that were carved
in in of course through the years that's
just an interpretation of what we
thought we were seeing
but whatever he really is whatever
whatever even that form is we can't see
but whatever he really is i imagine this
is even
is even beyond that but even that form
to look upon it to psalm is death
to look upon it to some is madness right
but like what is guaranteed is that if
you look upon it you're never going to
stop seeing it there's no one that looks
upon the face of cthulhu
and the safe right even even joe hansen
who ends up
who who gets out unscathed
is never fully free it's never fully
free because he has seen it he has
looked into the eye
he was looking through the eyes into the
face of an eldritch horror
all right lies in politics um says
thank you so much for super chat by the
way check out the lovecraftian science
wordpress
blog it elaborates on the
interdimensionality of cthulhu that's
actually an interesting concept
cool something i was thinking i think
about a lot reading lovecraft's work
because it's like
you you assume you we see these beings
in a physical form
semi-physical at least but it's like
that's not what they are it's definitely
not what they actually are
because i think i think the most i think
one of the most important things
they are beings of thought
they communicate to thought that is
their most essential form
thought and consciousness so kyle crane
thank you so much for your super chat
thank you for doing this
great stuff and thanks everyone that is
that is watching and listening
oh it looks like i have another super
chat that i missed one more
you should check out the keep by paul
you should check out the keep by f paul
wilson there's actually a terrible 1983
film adaptation
directed by michael mann the book is
great though you know i
i never i am not the type of person that
judges
a um a book off of a movie i know as a
fan of
horror and as a fan of george r martin
and as a fan of stephen king
that movie adaptations are rarely
as good as the book um it has never been
adapted well
um the mini series of stephen king's
book it
was fun for what it was but not not the
book
the new movies were just were worse in
my opinion um we can talk about that a
little bit the new it movies
as a whole i feel like we're worse than
the old one because it was like you had
an opportunity to go into it
it's 20. humanity has grown up give me
some cosmic horror
but they were afraid like the first
movie had no gore it was it wasn't scary
i don't know how you keep doing cosmic
horror and not making it scary
i get that it's difficult to do but it's
like i mean i feel like people aren't
trying
they keep trying to whenever i feel like
these executives say oh we're gonna do
some cosmic or some love crafting style
stuff
they always feel like they need to water
it down and they always end up
removing everything that actually makes
lovecraft work and that actually makes
lovecraft scary
and i'm just not a fan not a fan of the
way it's usually handled
for anyone thank you so much uh spaz
spazz tickas um for your super chat
for anyone who's new to lovecraft check
out the hp lovecraft literary podcast
that began going through every hp
lovecraft store in order
definitely check them out check them out
for sure
um and i'm just gonna check
my thingamajig before it looks like i've
got some paypals that
i'm not seeing sarah gray thank you so
much for your
paypal you didn't leave a message but
thank you so much
and thanks everyone that has sent in
donations guys it's greatly appreciated
thank you
i can't thank you guys enough for
supporting me and supporting my youtube
channel
and supporting me and my endeavors and
allowing me to live and talk about books
it's it's a lot of fun it's a lot of fun
javin says i love your videos well i
love you i love you guys
i love the fact that i can get up here
and talk about lovecraft all right
so we've been going for an hour and a
half we still got a little bit more to
talk about i think
um did we have started something people
are worshiping garth
at 20 minutes past the hour on multiple
streams and channels now it does it's
not even 4
20 it's just like 20 minutes past the
hour praise garth race
praise garth i'm saying that garth might
pop into existence because of all the
belief in him
it might cause him to actually exist
which would be cool you know that's an
interesting thing too
speaking speaking of that you've got god
so nunos again
yeah so that's the thing that's that's
an interesting point
about belief actually because i said
i said that
the gods don't care about humans the
lovecraftian gods right they just the
humans are just
they do what they do we need and i think
that is true but i do think
that there is something that they need
from conscious beings there is something
that they require from conscious beings
something that feeds them right
belief worship
that is why that is why they spoke
mysterious smoke that is why they spoke
to to the first men in their dreams that
is why
they they created a cult and made sure
the cult would never
forget and kept the arts because belief
in them is powerful right
so we did a discussion on the last
stream about the monster in stephen
king's it
and about like we talk about oh it eats
people but does it really
eat people does it need to actually eat
as an eat
physical flesh and if you really pay
attention it no it doesn't
it doesn't need to eat it it bites and
takes
it'll rip out a chunk of meat from
someone when it's killing them but
that's
just because the perception that we have
of monsters
is that what a monster does when it
takes you and drags you into his lair
is is it it eats you that's that's our
con
conceptual conceptualization of what a
monster does but it's really
the conscious energy that it's feeding
on
the fear and the belief that it's
feeding on so
yeah you talk about it said um
in the section that dave just read from
the call of cthulhu right
it mentions very briefly that no wonder
at the same time that cthulhu
woke up that a bunch of people had all
these
uneasy dreams in it and an architect
went mad and a boy went into a coma and
started screaming and all that junk
it's because these
gods are communicating
they're doing something to when cthulhu
woke up human felt it
humankind felt it there's a reason i
think specifically that it says when the
gods wake up it'll be a time
where humans are reveling and pain and
murder and violence and all that stuff
because that's what they feed on i think
they need it
i think they need the pain i think they
need the chaos and they need the belief
all right and that is that's like an
essential essential point right
and i i don't i that's something that as
we continue this lovecraft journey
and as i continue to dive more into the
work of lovecraft i'm gonna look
for signs of such things because
the cults and the nature of their
worship and the necronomicon
um we don't know everything about its
origins we know that it was written by
the mad arab
but it was divinely inspired
in the same way that you know they say
the bible is divinely inspired was
it was divinely inspired by the great
old ones in some way
and so it's kind of like instructions
right
on how to worship them and how to awaken
them
there's there's things that they needed
from humanity it says it says
specifically
that there were i said this earlier when
it's when the stars were right
there were arts which could reawaken
them
arts it doesn't say they just wake up
themselves it says they were arts
and what ends up happening it says what
a cult well i won't spoil that but yeah
arts so yeah they needed them they
needed their worship they needed their
belief
just like the thing in stephen king's it
needed the worship it needed the belief
it needed the fear
right so yeah
the mad arab abdullah
what a great name
what a great name okay now where were we
so how's everyone doing let me let me
look at the chat again
hopefully i didn't miss any chats
it looks like i did i missed a super
chat from adam
wolford i don't hollywood i think you
meant i don't think hollywood will be
able to do
justice if they ever
at the mountain of madness they would
turn it into a dumb action movie
let's hope not apparently wasn't it
del toro that wanted to do at the
mountains of madness but he ended up not
doing it because of freaking ridley
scott's
prometheus movie which like ah i like
prometheus but it's like uh prometheus
is like
yeah prometheus is like it has the ideas
but it doesn't go
forward with him and i would have i
would love to see can someone like
i mean there's like 500 of you here like
can you guys like go to
del toro's like twitter and be like hey
we still want to see your at the
mountains of madness movie like
forget what ridley scott was doing we
want to see what you were doing
because like it's the idea the whole
thing about prometheus is that like
earth was seeded
long ago by these beings from outer
space and that's what we are
um but the mountains of madness is like
it's that
idea but it's like it's a lovecraft baby
and it's
scary it's a scary story um like i said
i did a video about it
it's about a quest to antarctica um
and there's secrets discovered their
dark terrible secrets
yeah del toro needs to get on it del
toro come on man
i love me some gale guillermo del toro
he is so he's
he's the one i would love to see him do
some lovecraftian things
yeah netflix get on it you know netflix
is always throwing money
throwing money at freaking stranger
things oh yeah oh
very that that happened organically
actually stranger things
there's there's some lovecraft for you
there's some oh oh we're gonna
okay yeah let me make a note as well
we're gonna talk about some more
okay yeah stranger things
type that and then also another netflix
thing
lovecraft that i'm gonna talk about that
wasn't done well at all
so yeah stranger things does the
lovecraft thing kind of right with the
upside down and guadalarawada i gotta i
i don't really like
stranger things that much i kind of feel
like it's a little bit derivative
it's not my deal um but yeah they do do
the thing with like the
horrors that wait in the in the upside
down the monstrous things that can drive
you mad and
oh yeah if these things escape it'll be
horrible yada yada
um so stranger things does that but it's
kind of like it's
it's like a light version of lovecraft
they they never go
they never full fully go into the
lovecraft um
thing i agree lemming let me be stranger
things was cool for one
season one season they should have just
done one
season here's the thing people hollywood
does not get it no one ever gets it
just do one season do one story of
something
and then you don't have we don't have to
see it go bad because it hurts way
worse when it's like
it starts off a good show and then we
have to watch like four seasons of
mediocre to bad tv just do one
good season that's like inspired and we
like and we can get behind it and stop
like
we don't need like five seasons of
everything it's so annoying
or at least i heard the original idea
for stranger things was to like a
different story every season which would
have made way more sense but whatever
yeah they do love craft stuff but it's
kind of like
it's like babies first lovecraft so it's
never like fully going there with it but
just like little hints of it
but let's talk about something oh my god
i got
this is so funny i got into such a crazy
funny argument with like some randos on
facebook
always right rando's on facebook when
this movie was coming out
because i just was so exasperated
because i did not know how people were
thinking that this was a good movie
and i'm gonna i'm gonna tell you what
movie it was you probably can guess it
before as i'm describing it
um i could not understand how people
were thinking it was a good movie it was
a netflix movie
that was ripping off a bunch of
lovecraft ideas
but putting them inside of like this
horrible
generic sandra bullock
action horror trophy nightmare nightmare
fest
right and if you've seen the movie you
can probably guess what it was so it's
called bird box
right and
it's it's it's an example of a concept
that could have been interesting
if it was actually in the hands of
competent people i feel like
the core of the idea of this film bird
box was
was pretty good but the actual execution
of the film
was just horrible was just horrible so
the deal with bird box was um
you've got beings that are appearing in
earth and if you look at them
what's the deal they make you kill
yourself it's like the happening
basically they make you kill yourself
um because they drive you mad if you
look at them and we know it's 100
that they were going on lovecraft
because there's some point where a
character is like drawing a bunch of
what he's seeing and you see like a
bunch of like lovecraft tentacle
monsters and cthulhu faces or whatever
but the movie itself was
it's like it's like you have you have it
right there
focus on the cosmic horror of it all
slow this down a little bit and like
really get into what makes this scary
something is invading the earth where if
you look upon the visage of this
terrible thing it drives you
mad like but instead they focused on all
of these
completely generic horror movie tropes
where it's just like
a bunch of people in a house just
so stupid so i hated it i hate i don't
even remember exactly what happens in it
i kind of blocked it out of my mind but
i just remember it being oh they're
doing bird box too
are you kidding me please stop oh
god please stop god that movie was dumb
that movie was dumb
and it was like the reason i get angry
at these types of
these types of things mostly because
it's like when you have a court
you have you have the core of such a
great idea like that lovecraft idea of
like you stare into the abyss and the
abyss stares back
that's not lovecraft's idea that's neat
yet but that they were handling they
were handling it in the way that
lovecraft handles it right where it's
like you're staring into the eyes of
like some elders thing
which is beyond your comprehension and
the side of it it's so
terrible whatever it is it's like i
don't want to be here like wherever this
thing is i don't want to be here so i'm
out of here
but like it's so poorly done
that it's like funny right it's so it's
so poorly done that it's funny
and like just like according to the
point of like it was just like oh i i
was but like it was funny because i
remember just arguing with some idiot on
facebook being like
how do you think this is a good movie
how do you think it's a good movie and
they kept being like
oh you're just mad because it's like
inspired not everything has to be
exactly inspired by this
and i'm like i'm not saying that you can
take something and be inspired by it
hello stephen king hello freaking
monstrous and then still tell a good
story and be different and unique
but what they did was they took like a
lovecraft idea and then just
like i said put it inside of like a
generic horror movie and it was bad and
i hated it
i hated it hated it
there was a movie i watched called the
endless which is about actually i don't
want to spoil this one
a good lovecraft movie you can watch the
endless on netflix that one's really
good it's about these two brothers
that go back to this cult that they
escaped when they were younger
um and they rediscover like oh wait this
cult actually was
you know there's some lovecraft stuff
going on that's really really cool i
thought
and also in uh in yuzumaki
yuzumaki jungito do i have that i'm
available
where's my assistant he's not over here
well yeah
there's a manga that i really like uh
uzumaki which is about the spy it's
called the spiral of horror
which is definitely it's definitely got
a bunch of lovecraft stuff going on
as well so that's really cool but like i
said
there's ways there's ways to adapt love
draft i think it's possible
adapting lovecraft is possible and it's
been done it's been done
um they haven't a lot of ways they
haven't like adapted
direct stories really all that well but
the ideas
the ideas have been adapted well before
yes for sure
um someone just mentioned
the mist the mist is another
lovecraftian one
um another stephen king lovecraft story
about all these monsters that like
break out of this they escape from
another dimension and they're just like
out
it's a really good one and everyone's
like that's a really good one that you
should read for sure
write a screenplay quinn well i don't
have
i'll be right back guys one second
literally two seconds
not literally obviously but
as i was saying as i was saying guys
i have not written the screen play but
what
i did write as some of you guys know i
did write my own graphic novel
which is like shipping in december and
we're so freaking excited about it
tavia i've got my own lovecraftian
elements and tadia you can check out
tony is still available um somebody can
post the link in the chat
but um it's no longer available for the
original price it's a little bit more
expensive now i'm sorry i know
but like the whole deal was when the
campaign was on then we got the lower
price
and now the campaign is finished then um
it's a little bit more expensive
but yeah you can still actually order
pre-order the hard covers of tadia
as well as the soft covers and you know
we're very very excited to get this book
shipped so yeah tadia is my horror
fantasy story about witches and we're
very excited
definitely lovecraft influenced and a
lot of other things as well
oh someone said the lighthouse the
lighthouse is i've been tr
can you guys convince my roommate dave
to watch the lighthouse
like dave if you're in the chat look
everyone wants you to watch the
lighthouse everyone just be like dave
watch the lighthouse with quinn tell him
say dave watch the lighthouse with quinn
because it's so good
so the lighthouse is it's got um
i'm blanking on the names robert
pattinson i think
twilight guy and then also green goblin
what's his name i can't think of i can't
think of anybody's names
the green goblin from the original
spider-man um yeah him
willem dafoe so they're in this
lighthouse together and
you've got the older guy in the foe he
won't let the younger man
into the lighthouse there's something
there some kind of
lovecraftian entity that's there he just
goes he stares into it
he like there well i won't spoil what
happens but there's lovecraft stuff
going on
and then it gets really really
interesting and really really confusing
because it's like it's con it's it's
confusing for you because it becomes
confusing
confusing for the characters it's like
how long
have they been on this lighthouse island
like what it like
like what's going on are we going to be
rescued is something coming is
it it's it's just really cool you don't
know what's real
you don't know it's a thriller it's a
thriller it's such a thriller
and it's i think the lighthouse is
actually based
if i'm not mistaken the lighthouse is
based off an
unfinished um
an unfinished edgar allen poe story but
then they took a bunch of lovecraft
elements and put into it
and there's actually a few versions of
this movie guys
the robert pattinson one is the one we
should watch i know there's like
there's been like there's been a few
like trying to adapt this movie
that have happened that haven't been
good but the pattinson defeat one is
great and i really really enjoyed it
definitely some definitely a weird take
um an interesting take on
some lovecraft ideas for sure for sure
and that's the way you got to do it
right that's the way you do love craft
um it's not about like
adapting his stories like beat for beat
it's about maintaining the spirit of the
story right
that's the thing without adaptations
like sometimes you
you just can't adapt a short story as
like a movie
right sometimes you just can't do that
so you have to change things
and add things into them the way you do
that
is not by making a crappy made for kid
cthulhu graphic novel that can go in the
trash
um the way you do that is by staying
true to the heart of it
staying true to the heart of the horror
and just adding
adding in things that you know feed that
you know adding things that go with that
things that expand upon those ideas
even take elements from this larger body
of work and put them in
don't take things that don't exist and
add a bunch of bull crap about alpacas
nicholas cage like i am convinced that
in that stupid color outer space
adaptation
nicholas cage just wanted alpacas for
some reason it was just like give us
alpacas
for no reason for no because it was
literally like why aren't they llamas or
like sheep
or literally anything but freaking
alpacas but whatever
whatever yeah so i'm gonna put the
question to you guys um
since we're on the subject of lovecraft
adaptations
have you guys seen any adaptations of
movies
or tv shows that are um if not straight
up adaptations of lovecraft work
uh have elements of look after work that
are like kind of obvious or just like
it's clearly this is like influenced by
lovecraft
so do you guys have any examples i'm
sure you guys do and there's a delay of
course i gotta wait and while i'm
waiting i see that we have gotten some
donations from paypal thank you guys so
much it's greatly appreciated
let me just cover things up
all right nicholas cage
all right robot roberto roberto hello my
dude
you didn't leave a message but thank you
so much for your paypal the five bucks
it's greatly appreciated
someone says just pulled it let me see
what you guys are saying in the mountain
of
in the mouth of madness okay i haven't
seen that adaptation
the happening was one it's the happening
is one that gets crapped on
that's the thing the happening the
happening is a better movie than bird
box
same night shyamalan's happening with
with uh
uh marky mark is a better film than bird
box
absolutely absolutely let me let me go
uh pet my doggy a little bit she's sad
i'll be right back guys hey step on the
screen and say stupid stuff
stupid stuff or smart stuff oh okay well
that's much better
how's everybody doing i'm enjoying the
stream you guys learning a bit
um of course you guys know me lucifer
means lightbringer i have a youtube
channel
lucifer means lightbringer uh song
advice and fire mythology and symbolism
i am working on a couple of euron videos
right now and of course
euron is one of the key places where
lovecraftian horror is channeled into a
song of ice and fire
so i'll have a video out to the next
week you're on part one king of the
apocalypse
and then part two will be night's king
crow's eye
so if you guys again if you're a fan of
those two genres or not genres but
authors
george martin songwriting fire and
lovecraft you will enjoy the yarn videos
and then like quinn was saying earlier
we're gonna do a joint live stream to
sort of expand on those ideas
um and a lot of the stuff you said today
quinn definitely
had my gears turning as far as the old
ones being beings of thought
and we're talking about are there sort
of
spiritual elemental beings alive in a
song of ice and fire
spirits of some of the original dead
figures like night's king or azor ahai
or knight's queen or nissanissa are they
lurking
in the astral realm you know are they
you know what are the gods in a song of
ice and fire like we know the old gods
are actually green seers
so is the great other or relore some
sort of
entity instead of an you know just the
abstract idea of a god perhaps it is
some sort of ancient being
or the spirit of an ancient person yeah
you're totally good um
and we're talking about you know will
they will someone get a hold of these
beings
in a song of ice and fire euron is
obviously a great candidate
to do that since he has cthulhu like
squid face and let me just
scroll the chat up here so i can say hi
to everyone
yeah so i'm having a great time doing
those year on videos
and you know listening because quinn's
been reading
call of cthulhu like i said you guys
and so listening to his uh his thoughts
as he's been reading through the book
has been really interesting
and has definitely given me some ideas
the more i think about this idea of
azor ahai or knights king being alive in
the weirwood net
the more i like it and the more i think
that we're gonna see
something like that but you know you
were talking about
you know lovecraft stories being adapted
and it just occurred to me that really
it's the feeling of love past stories
and i'm sure you covered this that's
really the biggest influence
and any time like you read the prologue
of a game of thrones and that
that terror and shock that they feel
about the others one of the night's
watch brothers who escapes comes back to
winterfell and he's
almost senseless to the point where he
can't even describe what he's seen he's
sort of just babbling incoherently
his brain has been just fried by what
he's seen
that feeling it's so perfectly channeled
in lovecraft's stories that it's
it sticks with you as a writer as you
know george martin or anybody else
and so then you write your own stories
and when you want to tap into that sense
of awe before the terrifying unknown
you fall back on ideas from lovecraft so
his influence is pervasive no matter how
many of his stuff is
adapted or not but thanks for letting me
sit in buddy good stuff
so that was dave my roommate
good friend dropping me a song of ice
and fire knowledge
looks like i got a couple super chats
while i was gone
says the idea of gods needing people to
believe in them
is explored in much of gaiman's work
absolutely neil gaiman
american gods you have not read american
gods
check it out you can also watch the
first season of this tv show if you want
um second season was not good in my
opinion but yeah
the book really really good definitely
the idea of god's needing worship and
feeding on that needing it to exist
it's definitely there um and like i said
i think i think gaiman was definitely
inspired by dream quest for unknown
kadath
when he wrote uh sandman right next
super chat josh blackburn
says in the mouth of madness is
fantastic not inspired by lovecraft but
but event horizon just cause excellent
excellent definitely check that out yeah
that's a creepy one all right from
beyond
even the first ghostbusters have i seen
from beyond
i feel like from beyond is something
that i might have seen
at some point or at least heard of yeah
okay okay okay okay so what was i just
talking about though before i walked
away
we were talking we were just getting we
were just getting into me dissing bird
box a little bit more
so we were talking about lovecraft
adaptations and how much i hated
the god-awful uh bird box movie on
netflix that took all the lovecraft
ideas and kind of crapped on them
um real quick uh thank you so much
carrie
pid jion pidgeon i know
carrie prydia carrie pridgeon thank you
so much for your paypal donation of ten
dollars
um i've been working on a lovecraftian
sci-fi novel for a couple of years it's
really difficult
i'm sure it is really difficult to write
in that genre lovecraft was a master of
it for sure
for sure but anyway let's continue
crappy on the
the dumbberry box movie like i was
saying uh another super chat thing i
missed that one too
the book lovecraft country by matt ruff
is amazing why i'm excited for the show
but all matt ruff's books are amazing
i'm definitely gonna read that one
that's like next on my list guys like as
soon as i finished um
11 22 um 63 i'm getting on lovecraft
country
and then i'm gonna definitely do a
review of that one for you guys
on here anyway
the happening the happening and
happening um so someone mentioned the
happening
as far as like movies which are inspired
by uh lovecraft's work so the happening
if you don't know
and m night shyamalan got a lot of crap
for the happening
right and i feel like can i just say
this can i just say this
m night shyamalan gets way too much crap
for some of his movies right lady in the
water
is a great movie the village is a pretty
good movie
even like i like okay avatar not good
avatar's bad whatever avatar's bad like
the happening
not that bad it wasn't that bad it was a
little like silly but bird box is way
worse and i don't get why people praise
bird box but the happening is bad
when the bird when bird box is like
literally on the backs of the happening
like that's literally the story of the
happening
with like a lovecraft thing thrown in so
it's just like
people hate on m night shyamalan way too
much but whatever it's not like a great
movie but it's like not as bad as people
say
and then like yeah so whatever
the crapping
the crapping they say
yeah avatar was not his genre he should
he shouldn't have done he shouldn't have
done
avatar he shouldn't have done avatar
that was like uh
that that that wasn't good that yeah
that yeah i
he it's true he took the l with avatar
avatar is a bad movie avatar's a bad
movie and then like village is okay and
lady in the water is pretty good if you
understand it lady in the water
i think lady in the water suffered
science is
really good science is really really
good
science is a great movie and then so is
sixth sense but lady in the water if you
like
i feel like it was marketed wrong it was
marketed as like this horror thing when
really it should have just been marketed
as like an urban fairy tale which is
what it is
i gotta show you that one dave lady in
the water
oh my goodness see oh no my puppy's
crying so guys we're gonna go
for maybe 15 more minutes i got to put
my babies to bed um it's been a great
stream
if you guys have any more questions
about lovecraft we definitely like i
said
we're going to be talking about
lovecraft way more on this channel
i'm going to be reading lovecraft
country as soon as i can so i can review
it for you guys on this channel um
and yeah our next major video essay
is my big big call of cthulhu video
project
and what we're getting into with this
call of cthulhu video is basically we're
talking about
you know the real horror of cthulhu and
what he really means
and what it represents and we're getting
really really deep into this
the layers of it relating we're relating
it back to what's going on in the world
right now and real world things we're
talking about the
the legendary bloop i'm sure some of you
know about that the
the big sound that came from the ocean
that was really confusing
several years ago and a lot of people
thought it was cthulhu waking because it
was in the same part of the ocean so
we're going to talk about that in the
video
it's just going to be i'm really really
proud of this video it's multifaceted
and i
i'm really excited about my approach to
it and i think
a lot of you are really going to
appreciate it so yeah lots of lovecraft
work coming from this channel in the
future
like i said check out the lovecraft
playlist on my channel there's a couple
videos in it already
um the mountains of madness video that i
did the video essay and then also the
podcast episode i did with order of the
green hand a couple of years ago
and then also there's there's um my a
song of ice and fire um uh
mini video series the uh uh the ones who
move the pieces
uh the great game right that one is me
talking about a lot of the lovecraft
stuff in the song of us and fire
but anyway adam wooford says the first
dead space game and the lore is no doubt
lovecraft but the second and third games
aren't as good as the first
interesting i've never played that game
but i imagine that a game called dead
space would have some lovecraft stuff if
it was doing
if it was actually doing know its thing
right
because that's the thing about space i
mean space
and lovecraft honed in on this space is
scary space is a dark
terrifying place we can't exist in it
all right uh so we got it looks like i
got a
another paypal donation thank you so
much jason
the case of charles dexter ward is my
favorite lovecraft store i love the
channel congrats on today by the way
thank you so much jason for your ten
dollar paypal
thank you guys so much everyone that has
donated to this channel i'm so
i'm so impressed by you guys i'm so
happy that you guys are feeling me
and enjoying the discussion thanks
everyone that has sent in super chats
and thanks thanks everyone that has
donated through the paypal dot me
link and by the way the paypal dot me
link is the best way to get
donations into this channel and i
appreciate them all i couldn't
more the void the void let me make sure
the void is the film that i am thinking
about because i think i saw that one
the void that was the one
oh i didn't see this one this isn't the
one should i watch the void
is the void good is the void good i
think i was thinking about something
totally different
yeah should i watch the voigt
brother moon someone says the of course
you think i haven't seen the abyss
i've seen the abyss obviously the abyss
is a
classic science fiction film um
it's it's yeah a great movie
uh bloodborne is definitely super
lovecraft that's another game isn't it
another game i haven't played someone
says dune or riot
we talked about doing a little bit we
talked about um
even the ways in which frank herbert
pulls from some of those lovecraft
feelings right
we talk when he talks about the great
enemy because we talk about like
at some point in the demon universe
humankind like flees into space
and then about a thousand and a half
about 1500 years later they
come back running away from some thing
in outer space
and so the mystery of that the mystery
of like something so strong
that the new human empire fled it into
the old empire from outer space is very
very compelling and very very scary
someone says the void is okay the void
ain't bad the void is
fun cool cool cool maybe the void
is one they'll check out someone says
did dune get delayed
not that i know of not that i know of um
but um dune is possibly delayed i mean
it's
it's still slated to come out in
december december 18th but as far as i'm
concerned
i don't i don't see it in december 18th
guys i don't think we're getting it i
think it's going to be a next year thing
can i jump in on the super chat that
somebody just said
sure diego diego thank you so much for
your super chat i'm not sure what
current currency that is but thank you
so much
um have you ever thought about how many
mythos in history repeat certain beats
and how both fantasy and sci-fi repeat
those same beats do you think that in
the future people will consider
these stories as our own mythos of this
era even though
it's not religious absolutely we're both
fans of joseph campbell
and joseph campbell talked a lot about
how you know
mythology there's mythology for every
culture he talked about star wars has
modern mythology
i actually have an essay called george
rr martin is writing modern mythology
and the one of the key functions of myth
is that it's
highly symbolic and metaphorical and
attempts to speak to
the core of human existence the the core
questions that
apply to all humans across culture and
time and
you know every religion and every
culture has mythology and certainly
the stories that that we all i mean all
the stories like song of ice and fire or
dune
they have all the archetypal actions and
characters of classic mythology
and yeah so it's it's really i think
about it as a chain of transmission and
a tradition of symbolic storytelling
that you know skilled authors are
participating and it goes right back to
classic mythology so great question
and about like errors of history too
it's like it's impossible
to like see the era that you're in while
you're in it right
you have to like look back and be like
oh that was the 2000s because
if you look back at the 2000s now it's
totally like an
error but like when you're in it it's
like oh like what is that further we get
into the 90s the more it becomes obvious
how freaking cool it was yeah yeah it's
like can we go back
let me put my word in there yeah but
absolutely absolutely um
yeah myths and legends and stuff evolve
i don't know if
future generations will see our stories
as like
as see them as though we believe them i
think they'll have enough information
probably to know that they were just
stories to us but yeah it'll
worship this luke skywalker guy yeah
yeah we'll definitely develop
oh like there was a spider-man in new
york city yeah he saved them all the
time
not sure where metropolis is though or
this wakanda place that doesn't seem to
be on a map there's only batman that
kept society from chaos
in the late 20th century thank you so
much for your super chat though diego
and travis hammer thank you so much for
yours um
conan smoked lovecraftian monsters like
it was a buffet lovecraft robert e
howard and clark aston smith were pals
and their works overlapped a lot
cool cool cool
so i think you mean conan the the
barbarian
i've never actually i think conan was a
little before my time so i never
had i never really experienced conan but
yeah that's really really neat
like lovecraftian monsters are are so
interesting like it's
a lot a lot of people use
the old ones a lot it shows up in a lot
of places now like from south park to a
song of ice and fire to monstrous to
stephen king
to my own graphic novel tatia
which you can pre-order right now
someone can post a link in the chat
um but yeah um it's all over the place
and
like i said lovecraft his work has stood
the test of time people
are talking about it today because it
was good
and it was scary so the thing about the
man is we talked about in the beginning
he was a strange man he was a xenophobe
he was he was in agoraphobe he was weird
with women and all that junk
um but he also wrote
very very very very scary stories and
very very very very good stories
right and if the stories he was never
famous or rich while he was alive he was
kind of
kind of a loser his whole life never
famous or rich it wasn't until after he
was dead
that people found his stories again and
now he's
a legend of horror so posthumously he
influenced
the entire horror genre if you are a fan
of horror
right now like and it's like lovecraft
had something to do with it
so that's why to me it becomes even more
ridiculous
when we start talking about
let's cancel lovecraft and let's stop
reading lovecraft
because oh he had certain beliefs and
certain this like i was saying in the
beginning
no one ever talks about walt disney it's
very selective to come to lovecraft and
be like
oh he's particularly bad when there is
nothing in his
work in particular that's like awful
he's not like
talking about like white supremacy or
any of that stuff it's just
scary stories very very very scary
stories and they've stood the test of
time because they're very scary they're
very good
and yeah that's what i got to say about
all that
and also also as i said before
the guy is freaking dead the guy's been
dead a hundred years
it it maybe it would be another thing if
he was still alive or like he was a
modern
author but he's he's dead he died young
he's been dead for a very very long time
and buying the work of lovecraft reading
the work of lovecraft
does absolutely nothing to support him
and all that does and really it just
expands
your like it expands your your idea of
what horror is entertaining well at the
beginning of the stream so for anybody
joining late
you addressed it uh pretty eloquently at
the very top so yep so check that out
guys
so a couple more super chats the king in
red from dark tower series
feels hp lovecraft a lot of stuff from
dark tower seems lovecraft because i
think
that's stephen king showing like i think
one of his main influences and i
guarantee you i've never heard him
i don't know if i've ever heard stephen
king specifically mention lovecraft as
an influence
but i'm sure if anyone's ever asked him
he said it
because it's very very obvious to anyone
that's read the work of lovecraft
a few people are piping up to say that
there's a certain amount of changing his
views towards the end of his life that
happened i don't know about that
i don't know for sure um but that might
be possible
all right so someone says if you want an
introduction to conan the barbarian
check out midnight's edge retrospective
i like that channel a lot actually
midnight they they did a good dune
one i think as well it is a good intro
to the material including
um how it adapted during the years well
cool
thanks for letting me know about that
and ben frail
lumley's primal land books equals conan
meets the mythos
interesting thank you all for your
recommendations they are greatly
appreciated guys
and looks like someone else just piped
in
on paypal so let me get that patrick
gentle
thank you so much uh says quinn check
out die
farb by director han vu it's on amazon
prime
all right i have amazon prime so i can
definitely check that out i'm always
looking for great movies to watch
at night and like just wind down to them
who influenced lovecraft you know
that would actually be he spoke to him
in his dreams
no but that would actually be a cool
thing to do some research on actually
and maybe possibly do a video on maybe
like
his influences because everyone has
their influences everyone is influenced
by someone else
there is nothing that happens in a
vacuum human beings are always
influencing each other constantly in
ways that you don't even realize
consciously most of the time
so yeah everyone's influenced by someone
else
and let's see you guys got any more
questions
any more paypal hits
and feel free to if you're watching this
stream afterwards to like hit up the
paypal thing after
afterwards if you've got more questions
i'll try and get them on the next stream
or on twitter and also guys please
follow me on twitter um
can some of my mods please post my
twitter in the chat i'm sorry guys with
with stream yard it's really annoying
because you have to constantly like re
update your uh the description and i'm
not sure
if it's a way to uh make it default so i
never have my links ready
so please follow me on twitter guys i'm
always like chatting about different
books and different things
um and subscribe of course
please please please if you've been
enjoying the stream so far please hit
the like button
i've had so much fun telling you guys
about cthulhu and great old ones and
the work of lovecraft it's been so great
um but yeah
i'm gonna see if there's any more
straggler questions to get any more
interesting things
to be said from people i know some
people were saying they wanted to take a
look at
some of these lovecraft
editions that i have over here so i'll
show you guys these
so this is um this is the lovecraft
complete fiction that i have
so this is all of his stories
let's see this one's really really nice
i
really really like the feel of this book
i think i got this one from barnes
noble so that's that one
completed one there's so many different
completed lovecraft bound editions like
it's so hard to pick which one you want
like every time i see a new one i'm like
i need it
um pin donated a hundred i did i we got
it didn't we we
got it um we we got it mod married we
got that one yeah
thanks so thank you so much
okay so and this is the other one that i
have i
really really like this little blue book
here this cthulhu mythos
one um it feels really nice and on the
back of it it says
the oldest and strongest emotion of
mankind is fear
and the oldest and strongest kind of
fear is fear of the unknown
and you know that's that's love trap man
he was
like i said he was he was afraid of
things that he didn't know
and right a lot of you said he started
to change later on in his life i haven't
looked into that but yeah
that fear of the unknown shows up in his
stories and
that's a fear that everybody has
honestly if anybody's honest
most of us fear the unknown right
because like you don't know so it's like
we're
kind of afraid of it and honestly
honestly
you should fear the unknown me and dave
were talking about the astral plane
and like if the astral plane existed
like every other place in nature
the astral plane wouldn't be safe so you
wouldn't just go like
journeying into the astral plane because
there might be predators there
there's predators in every part of
nature so why not on the extra plane
the unknown is scary sorry i thought it
was one of the good parts of game of
thrones
when bran is wandering around in the
weirwood net realm
and then all of a sudden there's the
army of the dead in nike oh yeah and
bran doesn't know everything he doesn't
realize oh they can see me and like that
was
pretty well done yeah the unknown the
unknown is scary for a reason
oh yes for sure yeah there's there's
some love crafty and
field vibes to more [ __ ] quite often
i've noticed mm-hmm
so also looks like i know super chat as
well lions and politics kenneth grant
real life act like of aleister crowley
oh that's interesting claimed lovecraft
was subconsciously channeling occult
forces
now that's scary the idea of that is
scary right
the idea like oh they're just horror
stories but no actually this is real
[ __ ] and he was warning us
some the fifth circle whose name we
can't pronounce honestly guys you're
gonna love my cthulhu video because i
talk about
uh this phenomenon that happened in the
real world this big
sound that came out of the ocean in the
late 90s and we didn't know what it was
for a really long time so i would talk
about that a little
bit um you can see on the front of this
one it's got all these names
it says like um ancient dunwich as i
thought a bunch of like quotes
poison city of madness that is not dead
which can eternal lie and with strange
eons even death may die
i really really like this little one
here in his house at relay cthulhu
wait's dead dreaming
um yeah so i really really like this one
check it out i wonder how somebody comes
up with
all of that sitting in the bedroom i
know he was channeling some dark stuff
like what's that one this one's good
lonesomeness weights and dreams in the
deep oh
oh yeah that's one that i wanted to read
to you it sounded so
so um freaking gray joy
that was some gray joy stuff man it's
it's right before that part where he
says uh lonesome this weights and still
dreams in the deep that's from call of
cthulhu
yeah i don't know where it is it's
somewhere here it's really really scary
freaky line though freaky freaky line
yeah yeah yeah lonesomeness streams and
weights in the deep yeah i gotta find it
at some point
that'll be in the call of cthulhu video
anyway so yeah
what was i just doing what was i just
getting at i feel like i was about to
say something
else before that anyways
i think it is about time guys it is
about that time
that we wrap things up thanks everyone
for looks like i know super chat though
marvin martin
um some eldritch stuff seems more
supernatural and god like
what is the difference then it's
that's the thing when it comes to when
it comes to lovecraft it's almost like
there almost is no difference right it's
very very very very it's blended almost
you can't really fit lovecraft in with
like sci-fi or
like or fantasy because it's like
there's beings from the stars
and there is like i don't know how would
you go about
defining the concept of a word god like
across all cultures and times basically
it's some sort of being
that exists outside of our dimension or
outside of our understanding that's
probably like the most base level
definition of the word god
and that's what all these beings are
people worship the sun
like so can you imagine like things
whispering to you in your dreams and
leading you to idols that look like them
i mean that happens to me all the time
yeah yeah so like yeah think about gods
they're not they're not gods in the
sense that like
and the way we might traditionally see
divinity they are just extremely
powerful beings that are beyond this so
they're worshipped
yeah i was trying to say that like the
word god is what we use for
extra dimensional beings when they
become so powerful as to defy
comprehension then it's not a solid
or an angel it's an actual god
absolutely like the bat the wing it bat
things that show up in cthulhu
those might be demons cthulhu is very
very clearly something else
all right guys thank you guys so much
for watching
thanks everyone that has hit me up on
paypal it's so greatly appreciated
thanks everyone that has please like
please like um if you're
if you've enjoyed the stream please
subscribe if you're not subscribed
check me out on twitter one last time i
just gotta say i'm so excited
that my graphic novel tadia um
is moving forward we raised more than 50
thought we
we raised like 55 000 on indiegogo
to get this book made um and you can
still pre-order it right now
um someone has the link in the chat
please
um it's my own horror book as a fan of
horror and as a fan of fantasy my whole
life
obviously i wanted to give my own take
on horror and i'm obviously on the backs
of like
the people that have inspired me stephen
king neil gaiman
lovecraft george r martin um
as well as various other inspirations so
you can check out my graphic novel tadia
um i'm sure someone has the link in the
description or you can go to
quinnhower.net
my website and you can get to it from
there also my website guys
oh yeah that's the thing become a member
at my website quinnhoward.net i'm giving
away a
free book of tadia every single month
every single month
uh members of my website and it's
totally free to join in every single
month
a hardcover of tadia gets given away
randomly to members so yeah you can
totally join for free
quinnhower.net become a member and i'll
be giving away free books and junk so
yeah that's how it goes
but uh yeah the book won't be releasing
um shipping out until december with
preorder it's in the pre-order phase
we're getting it out we're finishing it
up doing all the logistics
it's really really good so yeah thanks
everyone
um and also um
the book will be on amazon at some point
and once it gets on amazon like in
maybe six months maybe longer than that
maybe like eight months nine months once
it's on amazon
it will be cheaper than it is on the
indiegogo page right now
because um initially the book was
15 for the paperbacks but now the prices
have been raised since the campaign is
over
so we have to raise the prices because
that's just the way the business works
uh whatever it was already really cheap
but thanks everyone for watching
thanks everyone for sitting here with me
and having the lovecraft discussion i
can't wait to talk about more lovecraft
stuff with you guys in the future
um and the call of cthulhu video is
coming for my dune fans the
chapter house video is coming after that
and um i appreciate you guys and i love
you
that is not dead which can eternal lie
and with strange eons
even death may die peace out